el objetivo de este vídeo es apreciar
algunas de las estructuras que podemos
encontrar hasta en organismos
unicelulares aquí tenemos la imagen de
la amiba chaos carolinenses y aquí
podemos ver una proyección saliendo de
la parte principal de la célula a esto
se le conoce como pseudo podo que hace
referencia a un pie falso todo proviene
de la misma raíz que podología que se
refiere a los pies pero lo que me
gustaría que apreciarán es que una amiga
utiliza esto para moverse o incluso para
atacar lo que quiere engullir pensemos
un poco en lo que se necesita para que
pueda hacer esto es decir para que pueda
crecer esta especie de pie falso bueno
para esto se necesitan todo tipo de
micro estructuras que se extienden o
contraen como sea necesario pero piensen
en la maquinaria que se necesita para
hacer todo eso así que la clave es que
muchas veces imaginamos que las células
son bolsas de fluidos flotando
al rededor pero en realidad son
estructuras tan complejas que incluso
los biólogos actualmente no comprenden
completamente cómo funciona todo y
siguen estudiando cómo es que ocurre
todo esto ahora otra estructura que
generalmente verán en organismos
unicelulares y que los ayuda tanto a
moverse como a mover otras cosas son los
cilios aquí tenemos la imagen de la ocs
itrich a tripa la chs que es un
organismo unicelular y es una eucariota
claramente podemos ver estas
proyecciones parecidas a estructuras
capilares saliendo de su cuerpo
recuerden que este es un organismo
unicelular y de hecho tiene un tamaño
bastante decente imaginemos que esto
corresponde a 30 micrómetros o también
30 millones y más de metro o 30
milésimas de milímetro parece pequeña
por nuestra escala pero en realidad es
bastante grande para ser una célula y
todos estos cilios se mueven al unísono
para permitir que el microorganismo se
mueva
a veces los usa para mover otras cosas
por ejemplo las células en nuestros
pulmones tienen sitios que utilizan para
mover algunas partículas de arriba hacia
abajo ahora la ocs cítrica triff a la
chs es muy interesante como célula
eucariota porque no tiene solamente un
núcleo sino que puede tener dos núcleos
y en el núcleo su adn puede estar
extremadamente fragmentado la mayoría de
los organismos tienen un número
razonable de cromosomas
por ejemplo los seres humanos tenemos 23
pares de cromosomas y ese es un número
muy grande pero la oxy trichet 'riff' a
la chs puede tener miles de cromosomas
pero lo más importante sobre este
organismo es como se aparece cuando este
organismo se encuentra bajo estrés se
une con otra ok si trichet triff a la
chs y en lugar de producir descendencia
lo que hacen es mezclar su adn así que
al aparearse cambian el aspecto de su
material genético lo cual es sumamente
fascinante
pendiendo de nuestra perspectiva
bastante romántico otra idea relacionada
es que en lugar de tener muchos cilios
algunos organismos unicelulares pueden
tener una sola proyección muy larga
parecida a una cola con la que se pueden
mover aquí tenemos la tan estudiada alga
verde conocida como clamado monas y aquí
podemos ver claramente que tiene un
flagelo que es una estructura parecida a
una cola pero que es extremadamente
delgada y podemos verla con ayuda de un
microscopio muy poderoso pero para tener
una noción de la escala un micrómetro en
esta imagen sería aproximadamente esto
entonces la longitud de este flagelo
esté aproximadamente un cuarto de
micrómetro y otra forma de verlo es que
si colocamos 4000 de estos de un lado a
otro
apenas tendríamos un milímetro así que
es extremadamente pequeño es muy
interesante que estos organismos que
probablemente se ven muy simples para
nosotros
son muy complejos de hecho ya existe un
estudio completo sobre cómo se mueven
los flagelos y cómo es que la célula lo
utiliza y lo gira para moverse si
descomponemos lo que sucede en esta
parte de la célula veremos que su
maquinaria biológica es muy compleja así
que estas células no son solamente
bolsas o cosas flotando por ahí en
realidad son estructuras increíblemente
complejas que hasta la fecha seguimos
tratando de comprender hemos terminado
pero nos vemos en otro vídeo